hello subscribers awesome people movie
fans as promised these are the
nominations for the first annual you
reviewers movie awards I'd like to
welcome the schmoes back and thank him
for doing this collaboration with me and
collaborating for the you reviewers
movie awards in general I've heard a lot
of great things people are really
excited about this and now we're going
to unveil to you the nominations for the
first annual you reviewers movie awards
we're going to go back and forth in this
video I'll unveil one the schmoes will
unveil one you know collaboration is how
we do it keep in mind these nominations
were voted on by you tube movie
reviewers that you watching your normal
people so this is what normal people
would nominate for awards all right now
let's get started the nominees are good
soundtrack best soundtrack inception
Hans Zimmer we have four veces
autographs who have Tron Daft Punk why
did you see that like Jeff Jeff Goldblum
the social network mr. uh radish nails
trent reznor yeah 127 hours uh an
orchestra and scott pilgrim first the
world Wow Scott Pilgrim this little begs
for Best Visual Effects we have iron man
2 followed up with harry potter and the
deathly hallows part one then we have
Tron Legacy followed up with inception
we're killing it off with scott pilgrim
vs. the world look at that movie gets a
little recognition like I said normal
people this screenplay adapted or
original best screenplay can be adapted
or original oh good the social network
uh inception 127 hours the King's
talking points and toy story 3 this
animated bill for best animated film we
have megamind followed by despicable me
then we have tangled there you go now
we're talking followed up with how to
train your dragon and of course finished
off with toy story 3 it's gonna be on
there everyone loved that movie oh no
actually I hated that movie because my
parents may be burned my toys and play
the piano Best Supporting Actress okay
Best Supporting Actress here we go with
the nominees from the you reviewers Mila
Kunis from Black Swan we're excited yeah
I would have liked to
said her name but I guess it's a little
creepy if I do it every time Amy Adams
miss enchanted from the fighter hailee
steinfeld true grit you like that
bulawayo it was the mod in the fire and
helena bonham carter from The King's
Speech so I don't look a lot of these
would seem to be getting close to the
Oscars but better but better yeah this
supporting actor for Best Supporting
Actor surprise to me is Tom Hardy from
inception couldn't call that I didn't
call that Jeremy Renner from the town
little hoodrat badass Andrew Garfield
from the social network there you go for
people who are calling snug Geoffrey
Rush with the king's speech and of
course Christian Bale with the fighter
this actress all right Best Actress you
ready and you're very excited about this
one yeah you can read the first name if
you like cool Natalie Portman for wax
one right Jennifer Lawrence for the porn
title where's bones to stop this all
right Nicole Kidman for the equally porn
title rabbit hole stop it from shell
Williams for Blue Valentine and I got
bedding for the kids are all right this
actor for Best Actor we got the snubbed
Ryan Gosling from Blue Valentine Jesse
Eisenberg from the social network
Leonardo DiCaprio from shutter island
not inception shutter island Colin Firth
from The King's Speech and James Franco
for 127 hours this Director Best
Director Tom Hooper I'm actually very
surprised Tom Hooper for the King's
Speech a really good movie I know I'm
just surprised that we have look it just
shows you a night out your boyfriend
doesn't mean a great the correct tom
hooper for the King's Speech darren
aronofsky for Black Swan David Fincher
for the social network on a danny boyle
for 127 hours have you're on the list
Danny Jenner welcome is it it I always
probably want more l11 christopher nolan
for inception I'm heard of that lies on
a comic book well done you reviewers
well done this picture and Best Picture
here it is here are your best picture
nominations from the you reviewers movie
awards the first annual you reviewers
movie awards we have the king's speech
followed by the town then going on to
the fighter then on to a hundred and
twenty seven hours brace yourself for
this next one scott pilgrim vs.
the world you know there's awesome like
I said normal people then going on to
toy story 3 followed by true grit and
then the social network people love that
facebook movie then on to Black Swan and
then of course you knew it was coming
inception and we have a new category
this is an exclusive for the you
reviewers Movie Awards most underrated
film now this one you might get get it i
like this guy lot i'm excited about this
category the underdogs the 16 seeds this
is a category specifically for the you
reviewers awards and that is most
underrated film no one ever gave these
films are shot but damn it they're here
to play the nominations are shutter
island Scott Pilgrim vs. the world the
American whoo ladies and gentlemen
legend of the guardians the owls of
ga'hoole the happiest that's awesome and
last but not least kick ass okay so
those are the nominations Thank You mr.
Johnson and there it is guys the
nominations for the first annual year
reviewers movie awards the votes will be
tallied up it will bring you guys the
award show that we're gonna break up
into four parts because I mean if you're
like me 30 minute videos and we're
actually going to divide and conquer I'm
like I'll have one the schmoes will have
the other i'll have another schmoes will
have the other one two three four
because it's a collaboration that's how
we do it like napoleon we divide and
conquer so stay tuned around the 17th
we'll have the first one up for you guys
and thank you for watching thank you for
everyone who's putting the word out
there making videos about it blogging
about you guys are bad asses check out
schmoes know i'll put a link right there
they'll have half the show so you want
to see it you know there's half of it
meaning the smells have been going back
and forth like all week we have some
really cool stuff planned for you guys
cannot wait to show you and the cool
part is if you hate these nominations
you too can make your own award show and
then people can hate that and make their
own award show it'll be like a rubber
band ball of award shows on youtube so
keep spreading the word keep getting the
word out there on Facebook Twitter here
on YouTube and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more